mesdames et messieurs bonjour voila je
m'appelle latifah je suis d origine
marocaine
je suis arrivé en france j'avais 17 ans
et demi j'avais enjoint de mon mari
aaron alors je suis venu dans une ville
qui ne parlent pas qui ne chante pas
mais il fallait s'intégrer s'habituer
d'aller vers l'autre surtout alors quand
je parlais pas le français c'était pas
facile pour moi mais c'était importante
très important d'aller vers l'autre
alors comment aller vers l'autre belge
allait vers mes voisins je souris
je parlais que les gestes et j'ai créé
ce lien avec mes voisins et grâce à mes
voisins qui m'ont appris ils m'ont
appris à parler
ils m'ont appris à sortir aller vers
l'autre et c'était très important pour
moi
alors jour par jour et ya monsieur qui
m'a dit m latifa je te prendras faire le
vélo j'ai rigolé j'étais grande assez
forte pour prendre le vélo mon âge et
j'ai appris parce que c'était important
aussi de papier parce que j'avais pas
les moyens de payer le bus alors d'aller
partout je souhaitais et indian certain
âge qui venait chez moi madame il a et c
d'amis m'a pris beaucoup de choses je
n'oublierai jamais et j'ai dit madame il
assez bien j'ai appris à parler le
français
j'ai appris à sortir j'aimerais faire
mes courses mais j'ai besoin de plus que
ça j'ai besoin d'apprendre à écrire mais
c'est un peu tard pour moi et ces dames
il m'a regardé et m'a dit latifah si
jamais trop tard vous avez tout le temps
pour apprendre
je vous assure et jeudi 18 ans vous
rendez compte
emma 18 ans 40 ans 30 ans 50 ans vous
pouvez y aller apprendre sait jamais
trop tard et je dis vous allez venir
avec moi parce que je pourrai pas les
seuls de ce centre est made in entier
grogne est capable de pousser cette
porte de centre social et tu vas rentrer
et j'ai pris mon cahier mon crayon et je
bossais cette porte de centre social et
c'est là où j'ai appris à prier à parler
à écrire à lire les valeurs décoration
de table de noël la cuisine voilà la
cuisine le la couture et surtout
d'apprendre aussi là le canal et orange
c'était vraiment voilà j'ai tout appris
le même les grenouilles vous savez j'ai
des grenouilles pour faire les fritures
j'ai ramené à mon mari j'ai appris plein
de choses et c'est là de s'ouvrir vers
l'autre d'aller vers l'autre c'était
important pour moi et je me suis bien
intégré bien intégrés et j'ai commencé à
prendre la vie commence à travailler et
j'ai dit à mon mari maintenant il faut
qu'on fonder une famille c'est important
j'ai fondé une famille j'ai cinq enfants
quatre garçons et une fille et ses six
garçons et 7 filles je les éduquer comme
je suis arrivé tout seul tout ce que
j'ai appris avec mes parents avec ma
famille j'ai transmis sans à mes enfants
et mes enfants ils ont réussi les cinq
ils ont réussi c'était envoyé c'était
heureux réussir j'ai quatre
fonctionnaires et un jeune qui continue
toujours ses études je suis très très
fier de mes enfants est un garçon que je
peux parler de lui un garçon qui était
pour moi plus qu'un garçon plus qu'un
fils c'était un ami et un confident y
met
imed c'est un jeune qu'il avait un grand
coeur que je voudrais parler de lui un
peu pour tout savoir qu'ils s'y mettent
imed il me raconte des choses qu'il
arrive dans la vie par exemple et aux
missions et les soldats y voyait des
chiens ils avaient peur des chiens
enragés et tué et un soir il avait un
gros chien et l'on suit et lendemain
matin il sortait et mon fils yves est un
homme
c'est quoi vous n'avez pas tué un chien
et j'ai écouté chef j'ai pas vu moi je
lui c'est un gros chien j'avais peur est
elle à la foule payer plat il faut payer
parce que tu as tué c'est une voiture 17
familles et cette famille cette voiture
qui fait vivre sa famille alors il faut
le rembourser et le soufflé retombe et
monfils mais ça va pas non que je vais
rembourser
non il faut que tu rembourses parce que
avec ça et le travail pour vous montrer
le coeur qu'il avait un mètre et matt
c'était quelqu'un de généreux quelqu'un
qu'il aimait la vie
quelqu'un qui est vraiment il avait un
sourire un garçon qui est plein de
projets aussi me raconter aussi quantité
aux missions à la frontière de libye il
m'a dit maman il y avait des plans de
mort il faisait trop chaud et on a fait
en tranchée pour intéresser mort et
elimam lemonnier de l'armée il est venu
à la fin il lui dit mais qu'est ce tu
fais maintenant il dit je vais prier
prix pour qui il a claqué la donne une
claque qui m'a dit maman je me suis
énervé et je dis fallait venir à vous
avons pour respecter ces morts avant que
je l'inter maintenant soit on perd et a
rien à faire pour montrer quand même
c'était un soldat de la république
c'était art d origine marocaine et est
respecté sa religion et il faisait tout
en même temps un soldat pratiquons
respectueux citoyen républicain c'est un
jeune qui est vraiment elle avait tous
ses qualités humaines
alors je vous présente je suis la maman
de i mète in zettel le soldat qui était
assassiné par mois maintenant le 11 mars
2012 à toulouse pour vous raconter un
petit peu le trajet la souffrance qu'on
a vécu et convives toujours l'assassinât
de mon fils le 11 mars 2012
mon fils a été assassiné deux bouts il a
refusé ce métagénome ahmad membre a
éludé métrage nous aimons faisait refuse
mais toi juno ont fusé déjà mais je
mettrais un juno tu veux tirer tir mais
je mettrais pas genou
et mon fils il est mort de venin
messieurs dames en émoi 40 jours après
je dis latifa tu peux pas rester sans
rien faire
d'abord je dois y aller voir où il est
tombé monfils est ce qu'il a laissé
quelque chose pour moi parce que comme
je vous dis ahmed
j'ai cinq enfants mais lui c'était plus
qu'un enfant plus qu'un fils alors j'ai
dit ptt m'a laissé quelque chose d'écrit
au sol et quand je suis arrivé ce
gymnase un dimanche après-midi comme
aujourd'hui et j'ai regardé partout dans
le sol et j'ai rien trouvé à part les
traces de sang et je commence à metals
lui frotter et j'ai crié très fort et
une craie d'une mère en souffrance
c'est quelqu'un qui peut m'en tombent si
une voiture qui peut s'arrêter
le gardien de gymnastique de sortir mais
là si je n'avais personne et je sais pas
qu'est ce qui m'a pris c'est je me suis
baissé jeudi à mende
je te promets je trouverais l'assassin
qu'elle t'a fait ça mon fils je te
promets y met et je me suis trouvé dans
son quartier de ma femme et de ma main
et je tombais sur des jeunes et j'ai de
poser la question s'il vous plaît savez
vous où il habite warm and manage s'il
vous plaît et un gène qui sourit me dit
madame mémoire marmara c'est un martyr
c'est un héros de l'islam il a mis la
france je ne vous regarde pas la télé
c'est incroyable et ces communes ont tué
la deuxième fois je regardais ce jeune
et j'ai dit vous savez que je suis je
suis la mère de haim est la mère de deux
premiers soldats qui assassine moment là
vous dites que marmara
c'est un martyr c'est un héros de
l'islam c'est ça l'islam et ses jeunes
et sont élevées y mon cercle et ils
m'ont dit madame on est désolé on est
désolé c'est qu'on vient de dire mais
regardez regardez où on habite madame ou
gagner sur ghetto fermi ont gardé la
république nous a oubliés
on n'est plus rien madame et moi je
regardais ce jeune
tellement la souffrance de leurs yeux
jeudi la république n'oublie personne
on n'est pas à la charge de la
république doit qu'est ce que tu vas
donner à la république
moi j'ai donné la république m'a
accueilli et moi j'ai donné à la
république
alors c'est à vous aussi de sortir de là
de chercher votre chance parce que la
chance si vous me la chercher une
personne qui peut la chercher à votre
place alors il faut bouger et ce jeune
il me regarde et me dit madame merci
mais vous êtes courageuse de venir
jusqu'à ici et j'ai regardé ces jeunes
j'ai dit vous savez j'ai fondé cette
association et je ne savais pas comment
utiliser mais je vais te ment la main ce
qu'ils étaient à l'origine de ma
souffrance
alors aujourd'hui je vais vous aider je
vous écouterai je vais essayer de faire
tout ce que je pourrai pour éviter un
autre amendement pour éviter une autre
mère qui sauf que moi aujourd'hui
alors vous savez les super souffrance on
peut paraît bien mais à l'intérieur et
en grande partie qui est parti avec mon
fils et depuis ce jour là messieurs
dames
je ramassais de combat germain sept
combats le message de vivre ensemble
d'aller vers l'autre de pas avoir peur
de l'autre et c'est important de
connaître l'autre
aujourd'hui il faut s'ouvrir il faut
sourire c'est pas grand-chose de souris
elhorga savez quand on regarde quelqu'un
et on sourit malo diallo qui viennent
plus facilement et c'est ça qu'on doit
faire chacun de nous aujourd'hui alors
je fais ça dans l'établissement scolaire
gt-one à travers les jeunes dans les
maisons d'arrêt dans la maison du quercy
à travers les faits me je fais tout ce
ce que je veux pour apporter l'ouverture
le vivre ensemble d'aller vers l'autre
sont voir peur de l'autre et ou non tous
on a un moteur ici qu'on doit le
demeurer pour avancer dans la vie c'est
ça que je apprendre à aux jeunes et de
s'ouvrir de parler j'ai fait aussi des
voyages j'ai ramené des enfants par
exemple en israël en palestine pour
connaître et notre civilisation
pour connaître la religion côte-à-côte
connaît pas différent
l'ouverture vers l'autre c'est c'est
très important
voilà c'est que je fais aujourd'hui j'ai
fait plein de projets pleins de démarche
l'association y mettent pour la jeunesse
et la paix je voulais faire au nom de
mon fils parce que ahmed
c'était un soldat de la république c'est
un jeune brémond qui était merveilleux
qui aimait la vie et les mets servir la
république on était fier de lui et
aujourd'hui cette souffrance elle est là
mais on doit aller en avance c'est très
important où alain messieurs dames
j'espère pour regarder le vidéo pour
voir un petit peu mon fils commence à
quel travail qui fait l'association et
comment on démarche aujourd'hui vers les
jeunes les jeunes vous savez dans les
quartiers on dit que les gens n'y arrive
pas je vous assure et des gens qu'ils
ont des talents magnifique des talents
formidables mais malheureusement on juge
les jeunes de quartiers mais il faut y
aller il faut aller sur le terrain pour
voir la seule chose qui je dis il faut
ouvrir ces ghettos il faut ouvrir cette
cité il faut donner la chance à toute
cette jeunesse il faut mixer tel
établissement scolaire pour donner
l'envié à l'enfant pour l'enfant qu'ils
se trouvent et se connaît lui-même qu'il
est vraiment français et soient fiers de
lui
comme je suis aujourd'hui comme j'ai mes
enfants et c'est ça qu'il faut c'est
très important
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
vous voulez la gamme havrais
[Musique]
bon
pour dire
et
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand je vois des
représentants en gérant les enfants
d'israël en palestine
et c'est là qu'on va faire de toi là
[Musique]
m
diam's aux autres
comme ça on
à
a minima
que ta joie des soutiens
ian schultz haye
by etienne daho j'aime pas nous fait
suivre des siens devant haruna boutique
champions
trois mots de cynthia
à
merci
c'est pour ça je vous dis l'association
aujourd'hui j'ai sauvé deux jeunes de
gens convertis à l'islam que j'ai tout
fait tout fait pour les aider ou qui ne
partent pas pour sauver leur vie
il avait d autres et je ne savais pas
mal de jeunes aujourd'hui voilà
l'association y mettre pour la jeunesse
et la paix elle sert pour le vivre
ensemble pour aller vers l'autre et de
pas peur de l'autre merci beaucoup
monsieur dame personnes
[Applaudissements]